[Musique]
la bayadère elodie grand favori du
répertoire de balai classe une des
pierres angulaires du théâtre mariinsky
[Musique]
thio rifaat élèves ne l'a pas vu 400
fois il ne l'a pas vu une seule comme
directeur de la célèbre compagnie danse
il connaît chaque petit au nom des
matchs morris hayes ce match par match
noah
à
fillon au lof des mômes droit de kent
state c'est comme une renaissance après
des mois de congé force iphone like it
because of the world
[Musique]
monsieur et déterminer les grands
ballets sont le repos malgré tous les
dangers
[Musique]
sauf qu aux buts
difficile de croire que la ballerine
solo et natacha kg va se remet de la
colle et la voilà au sommet de sa forme
dans ce qui sans doute la scène la plus
captivante de tous les sports
ils sont au moins 30 à l'avoir rattrapé
depuis la réouverture du mariinsky à
l'automne dont huit danseurs encore
cette semaine qui ont dû être remplacé à
la dernière minute
la grâce est l' angoisse se disputent
les résultats des tests situe à cette
attaque aux pilotes et aux communistes
moment j'aime auprès d'alex
[Musique]
le maestro christian knapp qui dirige
opéras et ballets se considèrent chance
[Musique]
et donc oui il n'ya que vides mais pour
épargner l'orchestré il a fait des
compromis
cette répétition est la seule au
programme cette semaine il a aussi
sacrifié des pièges et oui donc sixtine
s'effrite mais c'est un tout petit prix
à payer pour avoir le mieux de jouer en
plein pendant le show goes on dit qu'ils
aillent donc fink est une émission
people
[Musique]
difficile de trouver plus enthousiastes
que keira nous l'avons rencontré dans un
autre théâtre historique de
saint-pétersbourg le mirail l'ops qu
elle est venue voir la belle au bois
dormant de tchaïkovski après des mois
d'attentes
car lorsque le mirail love qui a été
rompu sa programmation au mois de mars
en raison de la que vides
c'était la première fois de son histoire
impensable pour un théâtre qui est sûr
mais qu'une révolution et deux guerres
monde si tu y as tu la boucle locale
où k qu aux rixes et dakota aux artistes
le directeur artistique de la dîmière
cartman est l'un de ceux qui avec celui
du mariinsky ont exercé d'énormes
pressions sur le président vladimir
poutine pour le convaincre de rouvrir
les théâtres à l'automne et les sauver
de la catastrophe financière avec des
millions de dollars de pertes
ok bottes ils ont dû s'adapter
tous les spectateurs sont fichés à
l'entrée on prend la température
seulement la moitié de la salle peut
être occupé mais ici aussi la coved 19 a
fait des ravages
le grand chef d'orchestre et directeur
musical du mirail love qui alexander
vedernikov on est mort le 30 octobre
on ne saura jamais si c'est ici qu'il
l'a contractée il avait donné son
dernier concert
trois semaines plus tôt
pour le premier danseur iban zaïtsev
retrouver la scène est une consolation
est une immense source de réconfort
le président et moi je me dirais qu il a
dansé tous les classiques du lac des
cygnes à roméo juliette ce soir dans la
belle au bois dormant
il est l'oiseau bleu qui enchante toute
la salle c'est un antidote à la déprime
qui nous affligent tous dit lilia pour
qui c'est une tradition de venir au
ballet avec sa fille
même si les billets se font de plus en
plus rare car plus la pandémie c'est en
russie plus la menace d'un autre
confinement plein sur les théâtres qui
doivent depuis mois de décembre se
limiter à vendre 25% des places c'est
tout what can à doha et fix it gets
better dans neuf
[Musique]
face à l'adversité ils ne peuvent que
danser comme d'autres l'ont fait avant
[Musique]